mich hat bewegt wie heute wladimir
klitschko ex schwergewichts weltmeister
der mit seinem bruder in kiew ist bei
vitali klitschko dort auch wohnt und
heute hat er offiziell gemacht dass wenn
russland angreift wenn wladimir putin
seine truppen schickt hier sehen wir die
bilder hat er offiziell unterschrieben
dass er dann an die front gehen würde
also wladimir klitschko steht bereit
sein land zu verteidigen gegen russische
truppen und das besondere hier heute
abend bei führte nach acht uns ist er
jetzt live zugeschaltet und ich möchte
von wladimir klitschko hören was ihn
bewogen hat der mann der überall auf der
welt leben könnte aber in kiew ist weil
er sagt ich will mein land verteidigen
wladimir was hat dich da heute zu
bewegen und was bedeutet diese
unterschrift guten abend ich habe mich
heute dass sein
müssen wie die ddr verteidigung
zu stehen im falle eines angriffs auf
die ukraine auf dem stativ
beteiligung ist auch initiiert wurden
von dem bürgermeister und natürlich die
leute die dir dazu stehen eigene land zu
verteidigen unsere wahl zu beteiligen
manni motivation gewesen ist die liebe
für meine stadt ihr für mein land die
ukraine
meine familie war letztendlich meine
doch da geht auch jeden kiffen die
schule und diese liebe ist nicht zu
stoppen ich glaube dass sich dieses
gefühl mit vielen bürger die in kiew
sind und in die ukraine sind im falle
ich hoffe dass sie nicht passieren aber
in vahle dass sie angegriffen werden und
dass wir auf einmal
russischen soldaten und demokratischen
boden haben was ist schon eigentlich
keine überraschung mehr dass das
passiert schon seit 2014 im osten der
ukraine mit gans und deeskalation von
queen
und es kann nicht so weitergehen
letztendlich es geht auch um
verteidigung nicht nur die rechte eine
breite demokratische wahl zu haben es
ist auch eine eine verteidigen gießen
massen für europa weil ich glaube wenn
der weg in die ukraine herrscht wird es
nicht nur die ukraine oder in einem
tollen der ukraine bleiben ich glaube
dadurch wird auch betroffen
wladimir muss ein bisschen mit wie geht
es den menschen in kia für jedes deiner
familie
vitali als bürgermeister von kiew ist
den ganzen tag unterwegs ist auch um
mögliche vorbereitungen zu treffen falls
ein angriff passieren sollte aber wie
erklärt man das auch zum beispiel deiner
tochter der familie was da momentan
passiert und wie würdest du den
deutschen die situation momentan
beschreiben es ist sehr angespannt der
situation ein kleines beispiel
als man jetzt noch die geht in die
internationale schule die mitarbeiter
von der schule ist und die
familienmitglieder von geschichtliche
botschaften die botschaften sind
evakuiert worden und zwar plötzlich und
schnell auf ein paar nicht die schule zu
also vorstellen
ich schuldig so und dann die schule
versucht zu reagieren weil letztendlich
dazu prozent der mitarbeiter sind
ausländer und der rest ist halt dann die
ukraine und
das ist das ist schon nicht zu glauben
was gerade in dem land geht weil die
leute sind sehr angespannt es ist keine
rede davon dass ist wahrscheinlich nicht
der fall sein wird sondern wir haben das
schon gelernt 2014
keine geglaubt dass russland die ukraine
treffen wird es ist leider passiert
wie gesagt wir wollen nicht es ist mehr
passiert und deswegen für alle fälle
sollten wir beraten sein und ich
verstehe auch dass die unterstützung von
dem westen auch in deutschland kommt
aber es ist nie genug unterstützung ich
weiß dass deutschland eine der lernten
der sich als nur
eins wir lernten und schnitt ganz vorne
nachdem krisenzeiten die ukraine
unterstützt wird mich dafür bedanken
aber wie gesagt es ist nie genug in
diese schwierige zeiten man muss sich
wirklich gedanken machen wie kann man
die politik auch die ganzen welt
verwenden würden nicht nur die ukraine
und wir fangen dann nicht nur mit der
ukraine aber von den königen das alles
auch an auch mit den frieden
aufzubewahren in europa wladimir du hast
du heute ein dokument unterschrieben
will muss leiden das vorstellen jetzt
sagen die leute die uns zuschauern der
wladimir klitschko dann habe ich im
boxkampf gesehen er kann überall auf der
welt leben du hast auch lange in den usa
gelebt
warum sagst du wenn putin angreift mit
diesen waffen wo er ja ganz schnell ganz
viele menschen töten kann willst du
trotzdem kiew die ukraine verteidigen
was kannst du dann tun gehst du dann an
die front wie sieht das aus die frage
stellt sich jeder es gibt natürlich
unterschiedliche meinungen eine kann
davon weg wären auch die möglichkeit der
an den schreibt sich das gesicht die
sich herausforderungen zu zeigen und
genau das habe ich mich entschlossen
weil letztendlich die liebe wie ich
schon vorher betont habe zu meinem land
meine stadt meine familie meine nachbarn
meine tochter wie gesagt das hätten wir
hier letztendlich ist es unser land
warum sollte wegen weglaufen und wir
haben schon das gelernt seine
vergangenheit dass wir für unsere rechte
kämpfen sollten und das ist nicht zu
stoppen wie gesagt wenn man dann von der
idee besessen ist diesen freien linken
zu führen und nicht nur da zu sein
wladimir bleibt bitte noch ein bisschen
bei uns in der diskussion ich möchte
gerne new yorks fragen oder du bist
stark holen ist lange im ausland mit
allen politikern gewesen was macht das
mit dir wenn du hörst wladimir klitschko
sagt ich bin bereit hier an der front zu
kämpfen ich bin eigentlich eher als
russlandfreundlich bekannt aber ich muss
sagen wenn ich in seiner option wäre
wenn ich in der ukraine leben würde
würde ich mich ganz genau so verhalten
das ist einfach und das große wort zu
bemühen eine patriotische pflicht sein
land zu verteidigen und dessen menschen
zu verteidigen und ich füge hinzu einen
verteidigungskrieg ist ein gerechter
krieg da gibt es gar keine frage also
er verhält sich patriotisch der fleet
nicht ins ausland nimmt sein geld nicht
mit sondern er bleibt dort und dahin
gibt es nichts zu kritisieren sondern
dafür kann man ihm nur gratulieren
franziska bandmann juli chefin natürlich
stark vernetzt in der deutschen politik
was macht das mit ihnen wenn sie da
sehen wladimir klitschko den kennt
wahrscheinlich fast jeder deutsche und
er sagt jetzt der bis bereit im krieg zu
ziehen und wir deutschen sitzen hier und
tu nicht so wirklich was oder ja also
erst mal kann ich mir ist es für mich
gar nicht greifbar das wirklich keiner
zwei flugstunden von hier entfernt sich
menschen entscheiden müssen ob sie im
zweifel eines angriffskrieges russlands
der eventuell erfolgen könnte und als
realistische option
verstanden wird dass sie sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie in den krieg
ziehen würden auch viele junge menschen
ich finde das unvorstellbar und ich
finde dass wir als deutsche uns die
frage stellen müssen was können wir tun
um die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine zu erhöhen um einen krieg
weniger wahrscheinlich zu machen das ist
ganz konkret die aufgabe von uns
deutschen auch michael scott eben
angesprochen und 2014 gab es bereits
eine situation in der die frage im raum
stand was passiert mit kiew russland
einen angriff wagen oder nicht und ich
glaube dass wir da uns sehr viel auf
diplomatie verlassen haben und am ende
gemerkt haben es hat nicht gereicht und
warum sagt ihre fdp jetzt nicht ja wir
unterstützen jemand wie wladimir
klitschko ja wir schicken waffen in die
ukraine defensivwaffen warum hilft
niemand klitschko ich sage dass ich sage
wir sollten unbedingt sofort
defensivwaffen in die ukraine schicken
wir sollten die ukraine auf jeden fall
unterstützen wir sollten auch deutlich
machen an russland das nicht nur im fall
eines angriffs sondern auch schon im
falle einer so deutlichen bedrohung von
einem partner von uns von ukrainern die
ihr land verteidigen wollen dass das
eine absolut schreckliche zustand ist
dass wir sanktionen deshalb auch
verhängt werden ich bin der meinung dass
wir die russische regierung
sanktionieren sollten wir sollten die
zivilbevölkerung da in geiselhaft nähmen
aber wir sollten ganz klar ein zeichen
setzen wer so etwas macht wer die
ukraine so drastisch bedroht der kann
mit deutschland nicht rechnen und der
hat im gegenteil mit sanktionen und mit
ganz klaren defensivwaffen und
botschaften von deutschlands seite zu
rechnen vorfalls wie nehmen sie die
diskussion war sie sind kabarettistin im
tv immer wieder präsent die menschen
kennen sie wenn die deutschen über die
ukraine sprechen dann ist das thema in
immer noch fern oder wir nehmen sie das
wahr
das eine was eigentlich unfassbar ist
das im jahr 2022 mit zu archaischen
methoden immer noch die
auseinandersetzungen geführt werden
müssen was ich habe ja schon gerne im
jahr 2015 habe ich als eine bühnenfigur
hatte ich dieses olga geheim die kowar
und ausgesprochen über russland und
geostrategische und hat dann
aufgedröselt zum was ist geostrategisch
strategie ist wenn du und deine
gartenzwerge so aufstellen dass nachbar
sich darüber ärgert dass
man das zurückführen müssen auf alles
was passiert ist deswegen bin ich also
ganz im gegensatz zu ihnen nie für
waffenlieferungen egal wohin sondern
immer für sämtliche mittel auszuschöpfen
friedlich auseinander setzen auch die
schulden nicht so einseitig zu sehen das
würde jetzt zu weit führen deswegen
halte ich mich dann etwas aus wir wollen
noch einmal mit heimtrainer dann
vielleicht das ist ja nicht sind noch
die regierung ist für die menschen es
sind ja die millionen russen sind
millionen deutschen millionen und
katharina und da sind ein paar wenige
die millionen ins verderben führen und
das sollte meinem kopf habe ich meine
frau hatte mir wenn du die diskussion
hier auch verfolgst du bist viel mit
deutschland kontakt natürlich weil du in
hamburg auch noch eine wohnung hast wie
erlebst du das und was genau bräuchte
die ukraine in diesen tagen in diesen
wochen wo könnte deutschland mehr helfen
als bislang
ich glaube schon dass wie gesagt es ist
nie genug unterstützung
auch wenn man schon über die waffen
spricht dann spricht man über die viert
eigen machen und nicht doch ganz weile
einen griff also wie sind deine
freundlich hier nation die keine morgen
waren angegriffen
irgendwo auch eine geschichte wie er wie
gesagt mit unserer regierung 2017
entschlossen haben richtung europa
richtung westliche qualitäten westliche
demokratie frei weil wir wissen wie das
mit
anderen menschen lernen auch passierte
und wie komplex das ist wie menschen
auch oft unter druck werden also ist es
definitiv die wahl die wir
genommen haben um mich viel spiel
verstehen dass auch und dafür muss man
auch geld und wir sind auch bereit ist
zu kämpfen und das haben ja auch in den
vergangenen jahren gemacht als nation
und wir standen wir stehen zusammen und
wie gesagt was die unterstützung
betrifft vor allem auch den verstand
weil ich verstehe das auch was medien
dann ganz oft racing machen und die welt
nicht so wirklich darstellen so genannte
ist ein gutes buch ein sprichwort ein
deutsches sprichwort lugen hat
letztendlich noch ein bisschen zeit und
wir werden schon verstehen was
eigentlich passiert in nur ganz schnell
schon jetzt es ist nicht ein ein
interner konflikt wir wissen schon das
ganze equipment kommt von russland und
estland
wo die junge frau nicht eine frage hier
unter den nägeln an wladimir wenn wir
nach vorne schauen
können sie sich vorstellen dass einer
der beiden klitschko-brüder vitali ist
er bürgermeister in kiew bei der
nächsten präsidentenwahl antritt denn
nach meinem eindruck ist herr selensky
ja nicht der stärkste präsident im
moment
wissen sie was die präsidentin betrifft
es immer um kritische winkel blickwinkel
kann man natürlich hier die führung
machen sagen um diese kritische zeiten
ich werde jetzt keine präsidenten
kritisieren
natürlich es gibt genug was man besser
machen kann absolut aber in diese
schwierige zeiten glauben statt uns zu
teilen um herrschen wir sollten schon
eine einigung haben manchmal fällt es
uns in europa auch diese einigung und
deswegen meine meinung nach dass europa
oder die westliche welt manchmal schwach
ist kann sie waren juli chefin wladimir
hat hier gerade gesagt defensivwaffen
werden das richtige verband man ihn
trinkt auch noch etwas unter den nägeln
ja ich bin der meinung dass wir defensiv
waffen liefern sollten alleine deshalb
weil wir den krieg verhindern müssen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein krieg
entsteht durch russland die vermindern
wir indem wir die verteidigungsfähigkeit
der ukraine erhöhen deshalb möchte dass
an dieser stelle nochmal betonen und ich
möchte auch ganz konkret sagen dass die
bundesregierung hier eine klare
botschaft senden solche und sich nicht
ich hab mich es hat mich sehr irritiert
dass die spd extra eine klausur machen
musste um dann herauszugehen mit der
botschaft die aggression ging hier ganz
klar von russland aus ich denke jeder
der sich informiert er weiß auch schon
im vorfeld einer klausur also da möchte
ich die bundesregierung dazu auffordern
eine ganz klare haltung zu zeigen und zu
sagen wir stehen an der seite der
ukraine das tun wir herzlich dann klare
worte von der juli chef wladimir
klitschko vielen vielen dank dass du
heute aus kiew und zugeschaltet war